russia's president vladimir putin is
threatening to hit new targets if the
west sends ukraine long-range missiles
it's not clear whether putin is
referring to targets within or beyond
ukraine's
borders if long-range missiles are
supplied we'll make certain conclusions
and use our own means of destruction
we have enough to strike a target we
have not yet been hitting
i am now joined by dw's russian analyst
constantine egot in riga constantine uh
the russian president they're not
exactly talking softly what do you make
of his comments
well putin has been talking something
about for quite a long time wasn't
talking softly for quite a long time we
heard threats of uh
using nuclear weapons at least tactical
nuclear weapons before from him so this
is nothing new i suppose that this shows
that putin is worried about increasing
western supplies uh to ukraine and what
is even more important the fact that
judging by
nato uh military military analysts with
whom i had a chance to speak in the last
couple of weeks
the
state of preparation of uh ukrainian uh
army uh for use of these new weapons
systems uh is increasing and probably
they will be fully operational by the
end of june so i suppose we should read
it as a warning uh but also as a sign of
worry that uh new modern western
weaponry uh will hit the russian army in
ukraine really really hard
and it could very well reverse the the
tide in the east which his forces
currently are
are winning um what do you believe that
he believes the effect of his words will
be
well he believes that uh
ukrainians will be careful in using the
weapons and for example not hit the
russian mainland on which they seemingly
promised to washington but you know uh
there are lots of shifting things uh
during this conflict which change
basically from day to day uh my feeling
is that uh his retaliation may be
very simple he'll be hitting residential
areas of major cities like eve and uh
uh
maybe if he feels that ukrainians are
overusing the new weaponry uh i think
what we've seen in the last few weeks uh
is this constant towing and throwing
this kind of swinging uh between uh
ukrainians saying that well they really
want to win
and the west trying to tell me well
could you win more gently especially
several european countries were pushing
uh a cave to do that but i think by the
time ukrainian army really acquires
mastery of these newly delivered western
weapons we'll see what kind of choice
finally president zilenski will make you
just made a reference to several euro
country european countries uh expressing
a little bit of caution as you know
french president emmanuel macron has
warned against humiliating russia in
order to leave diplomatic doors open
when the fighting stops ukraine is of
course not happy with those comments
is there widespread sense in the west
that it's indeed dangerous to corner or
humiliate putin
well
frankly speaking this is an old song
song in paris and there's nothing new in
what macron said um there are
people that sympathize with him in
different other european capitals
probably in rome probably some in berlin
um i think that um the west is divided
on that
we know that for example the united
kingdom central europe the baltics part
of the nordic countries are actually
pushing for a much tougher line
against
putin
while paris berlin to some extent rome
uh are trying to basically uh limit uh
the extent to which ukraine could
respond and the west could respond to
putin's aggression i suppose the
perception is that putin if cornered
will become really uncontrollable and
will do some um really horrible things
uh but on the other hand we can say that
putin always counted on the west
considering him to be so mad so
unpredictable that it will try to
placate him and in this respect i think
what macron probably after these 100
hours he said he talked with putin for
about 100 hours all in all in the last
sort of half a year
and i think that macron seemingly
doesn't understand that this is exactly
what putin wants he wants the west to
see him as so unpredictable and so
dangerous that it will limit its
pressure we'll have to leave it there
that's constantine egard in riga many
thanks as always
let's go straight to dw correspondent
nick connolly who is standing by in kiev
hello nick what are ukrainians making of
putin's comments
well obviously the take here on the
streets of kiev is that this is a sign
that the russians are genuinely worried
about the prospect of these weapons
being delivered it has to be said that
these are not long-range missiles in the
sense of cruise missiles or anything of
the kind that russia has that can go
thousands of kilometers indeed the
missiles that hit kiev this morning the
russian missiles will launch over the
caspian sea thousands of kilometers away
what we're talking about here are
weapons that can be used with the
rocket systems rocket launch systems
that are being delivered
presently which at present only have
about 80 to 100 kilometer range and
there is the option to go beyond 100
kilometers up to maybe 300 kilometers uh
in terms of the munitions that the
americans would send the ukrainians so
this is not anything that would give
ukraine capacities on par with
more modern militaries in western europe
or in north america but it would allow
ukraine to really hit russia's supply
chain hit its supply lines and really
give it a significant
option to really push the russian forces
back while staying at a safer distance
and that is something obviously the
russians think would allow ukraine to
really move forward on battlefield
yeah we clearly heard what uh president
putin said earlier is the city worried
this could be the start of more strikes
to come over western weapons supplies
i mean russia and the kremlin vladimir
putin in particular have been making
threats all along basically he's been
threatening nuclear war should the west
supply ukraine with more sophisticated
weaponry so this is really nothing new
and indeed what people are talking about
more here in ukraine right now is the
fact that a russian cruise missile was
detected on the security cameras of one
of ukraine's biggest nuclear power
stations today the fact that russia is
willing to fire weapons that have been
proven in the past to fail to go off
target so close to a huge nuclear power
station that really for them is a sign
that russia is not really caring about
the risks and whether or not they try
and attack ukrainian government
buildings the presidential palace here
in kiev i think that's less crucial than
just the willingness to really pump up
the pressure now that russia's military
isn't doing too well in the battlefield
okay on that ukraine is claiming it has
recaptured large parts of severo donetsk
if that can be verified what is the
significance of that development
well obviously this has been the central
battle on the donbass front for more
than ten days now and there have been
predictions uh time and time again from
western analysts that it was just a
matter of days or maybe a week at most
before russia took over the city now
that russia has concentrated its forces
on a very small part of the front lines
learning from the lessons of the early
months of the war where russia spread
itself too thinly but even there it
seems russia is not achieving the kinds
of gold despite huge
huge numbers of uh soldiers there but
also a huge superiority in terms of the
fire power and the munitions available
to the russian forces uh obviously
journalists are not freely able to move
around there and so it's difficult to
verify but just the fact that there are
ukrainian troops still in civil and yet
the russians haven't been able to hoist
their flag over the entire city that
will be seen as a victory here in kiev
okay dw correspondent nick connolly in
kiev thank you
well despite the latest attacks in kiev
there are some bright spots right now
ukraine's national football team is
playing against wales in cardiff for a
spot in the world cup and dw's rebecca
ritas is soaking in the atmosphere at a
pub
rebecca
tell us what's the mood like
[Music]
i'm having a lot of trouble hearing you
eddie so i hope that i'm getting this
bit right and that you are to me now but
it is pretty tense here i'll give you
that but it's quite different from the
tension that we've felt in the city uh
in the recent in recent months and it is
a nice reprieve for people here who are
able to to enjoy some some normalcy in
in the football and one of those people
is yuri and he joins me now yuri just
how important is today's match for
ukraine
it's really important much for us
because this is the final match before
we can
go to the world cup and it's really
important for us to speech from war
theme to something more pleasure to us
even though today russia strike seven
missiles six missile tokey we are still
here and we are trying to enjoy our
lives and we try to switch for something
more pleasant for us than the war team
now we're just coming back from halftime
and wales is one up how do you think the
country will react if they don't make it
through to the world cup today
i think we will handle somehow this
situation because it is not
the biggest problem out nowadays and
this is just a football there will be
another opportunity for us to
play the world cup or euro cup so this
is not the end of the world for us
all right thank you very much we
certainly wish you luck for the second
half
so eddie there you have it a nice light
reprieve for people here who've been
through pretty intense day with shelling
in the morning to be able to enjoy some
normalcy uh and watching the football
and everyone here hoping that ukraine
will make it through to the world cup
okay rebecca thanks for that revere
caritas there in kiev many thanks
you